hey everyone i'm back from texas and uh
the batman video i think was a great
opportunity to find out a little bit
more about how realistic
these superhero tropes are and i've got
another idea superman clark kent
people say that superman's disguise as
clark kent is not possible i mean yeah
obviously look you shall send me a
picture of henry cavill as clark kent
can you show them a picture of henry
cavill at superman come on they'll be
like henry cavill in both pictures like
glasses and a little like here
where'd nico go
here i am oh
nico
yeah come on i mean it's never gonna
work it doesn't work everybody knows
clark can't superman he's a nice guy
they don't want to piss superman off so
just they go along with it look if
there's one superhero that i like almost
as much as batman it's superman first of
all it's not just a curlicue and some
eyeglasses okay he's an alien from
another planet and second of all it's
about the performance as we learned with
the batman episode it's not just him
disappearing it's a little sleight of
hand it's a little misdirection it's a
little smoking mirrors this isn't just
him putting on a disguise kit this is a
lifestyle this is a performance this is
a show i think it's definitely possible
to trick people to actually think that
you're a different person just like
superman look if you can fool one person
in this office into thinking that you're
not jake watson i will be very impressed
i will admit in front of a million
people on youtube
that i was wrong that it is possible in
real life but i don't think it is but
i'm curious to see what you come up with
deals
see superman's clark kent disguise would
work scientists claim now it's science
if you weren't a personal friend of
either clark kent or superman you could
be tricked by his glasses like everyone
else in metropolis oh what's up even the
smallest change of someone's facial
appearance like wearing glasses can
shift our ability to identify them if we
don't know them so we're gonna go full
hiding in plain sight on this okay
that's the idea
i think it's possible to fool at least
one person in this studio with a pretty
basic disguise into thinking that i'm a
completely different person come on in
close the door behind you
hey how are you my name is chip
my name is chip metzinger chip chip
metzinger and i am here
to uh look at the books chip metzinger
never misses a count
before we do anything else i'm gonna see
if i can fool some people just like
clark kent does
and the books look good in here
that's obviously jake
listen it's not jake okay it's chip
metzinger uh jake's character that he's
playing jake is a decent actor i
acknowledge jake's performance that's
happening behind the character chips
performance by the way
[Music]
[Laughter]
who are you talking to
jake you get glasses or something
that's jake for sure no it does not
hi jake
what's going on what's up dude hey good
to see you hey jordan right yeah good
memory yeah thank you remember you from
the commercial we did last year oh yeah
what that's awesome
it like drew more attention because it's
like clearly jake was wearing something
he never would
hear from youtube corporate what's this
here you guys are uploading videos on
your own website jake what are you doing
who's jake
you
surprise
what gave it away what gave it away the
general
jakeyness of it
jay ketus
oh no it's coming out
you're doing the superman thing you're
doing the superman thing i think though
except for everyone knew it was you
turned out it doesn't work wait jake
jake
are you trying to prove that like
superman couldn't possibly fool anyone
by being clark kent
[Music]
well i think the chip metzger disguise
did not go well because everyone here
knows me way too well it's just not
enough detail and so if i'm gonna pull
this off i need to go deep cover i need
a completely different persona and i
need to set it within a context so no
one is looking for it it's about
changing what people are looking for
you're trying to come up with a set of
circumstances where there's no plausible
reason why they would be looking for you
to begin with that's the sleight of hand
that you need to focus on so what i need
to do just like superman is i need to
come up with an alter ego who is my
jake gent jesse jenk jerk jank
george
[Laughter]
jerry jerry jank yeah jenkins jerry
jenkins i'm just a humble ac repairman
and i'm coming by the studio to do some
repairs on the air conditioning units
perfectly plausible perfectly reasonable
something we actually talked about
having somebody come by and do so if i
just put on a humble ac repairman
uniform and i come by his jerry jenkins
probably gonna fool some people before i
do that there's one person who knows how
to play me better than anybody else in
the world we're gonna talk to him get a
little advice on how he plays me so that
i can understand how to not play me
what's up son what up son doing well
doing well man no one else in the world
knows how to play me jake watson better
than you welcome thank you for the
sponsored segment by squarespace
what are some of the things that you did
to perfectly personify me
gotcha
why don't you
meryl street
meryl streep
yeah well i can't play a woman that
would be too obvious i'm not saying that
today i'm saying go go deep inside meryl
streep son oh figure out what meryl
streep does to get into her characters
oh she's one of the greats she's one of
the goats absolutely meryl streep is the
opposite
[Music]
what's up guys um if you've been a fan
of this channel for a long time you know
i love to cook and i love to cook for my
friends so i'm going to tell you a
little bit more about today's sponsor
hellofresh and their service because
hellofresh makes cooking at home in a
super full and satisfied meal super easy
and convenient so let's jump in hello
fresh is america's number one meal kit
they give you fresh pre-portioned
ingredients with seasonal recipes
delivered straight to your doorstep they
have a ton of different meals every week
they have 50 recipes for you to choose
from so you don't have to think about
what's for dinner you can just choose
your meals and then delivered right to
your door today we're going to go with
the crispy parmesan chicken can't go
wrong with chicken but you got some
healthy sides and stuff i think they
sent us enough for four so boom comes
with this awesome recipe packet you get
to see what the finished product looks
like see all your ingredients what comes
with it there's zero food waste when you
cook with hella fresh because they give
you the exact portions
of every single thing you need for each
meal lots of carrots lots of produce we
got some panko and my current weight
loss drain the best thing about hella
fresh is it actually helps you reach
your goals because there are low carb
low calorie options there's keto options
and it can help you basically stay on
track with whatever diet that you might
be on or a lifestyle you might be on so
that's also super convenient hello fresh
is a great option to get you out of that
kind of mundane same meals every week
routine you know my favorite things
about hellofresh is actually just the
cooking techniques you know i might cook
a meal but then there's a technique that
they taught me and i've carried those
techniques into other dishes i've cooked
this is a new technique i've never tried
mound in the chicken with the parmesan
mix i'm excited to see how the results
turn out because i've never done this
before
go to hellofresh.com and use the code
cordocrew16 for up to 16 free meals and
three surprise gifts hello fresh is
hooking you guys up
[Music]
looks good that looks good look at that
crust on that chicken
we're gonna go enjoy these meals but if
you want to join in on hellofresh go to
hellofresh.com and then use the code
corridor crew 16 for up to 16 free meals
and three surprises whatever that means
um
we've got everything we need for the
costume
physically but you know what it lacks
the inner jerry jenkins
i'm going to call on everything brett
has taught me find my inner meryl and
really develop jerry jenkins
the air conditioning the air
conditioning the air the air
conditioning the air conditioning
the air conditioning larry
it's too much that's too much i don't
think so
it's really about making your silhouette
not jake watson
over here
[Music]
so i'm going to try a little marlon
brando trick he used to take cotton
balls and put him in his mouth
how's it going larry
hey good i'm here with the heating and
air conditioning try going higher hey
good here with the heating and air
conditioning
way less enthusiastic
here to look at the ac unit pretty good
yeah well you got your problem is that
uh probably have you tried cleaning the
filters yet
try speaking from your mouth instead of
your diaphragm is that possible
have you tried cleaning out the air
conditioning
they're coming down and they're
they're only exiting with the same thing
as my breath have you tried uh checking
the filters
dude this is going to work jake
the air comes in
and then it clogs up the filters and say
what you got to do you got to open up
the front and what i like to do is just
i just wash them out if you want me to
take them outside i can wash them
outside
well yeah i think i have a i'm going to
hear this what i'm focused on is my work
am i good out in front of the loading
dock what i usually look for
is
is it plugged in
after much diligent research i think i
have the character of jerry jenkins to a
t also i put it in context i talked to
jordan i said hey jordan there's gonna
be an air conditioning guy coming by
could you please let everybody in the
studio know this way everyone is
expecting a new unfamiliar face to be in
the studio and they will not be
suspecting that it's me so i've got the
look i've got the talk i've got the
context and now i'm gonna go in and i'm
gonna see how many people i can fool by
becoming jerry jenkins
jerry jenkins
oh yeah i'm here for the air conditioner
hi
here for the air conditioning
hi
i spoke with jake about the air
conditioning yes okay
okay
how many units do you guys have
six
six okay have you cleaned when's the
last time you cleaned the filters
okay
oh
hi
how did you do that voice i'm just i'm
just is jerry moore here hi
hair conditioning i was so nervous i was
like this guy's weird i was like but i'm
not gonna
judge
and then he wouldn't look out of his
case i feel like there's nothing in your
bag what are you looking at
i got jordan which is a great first step
and now she can be my accomplice the
next test begins when she takes me
inside the studio i've heard that the
entire group of effects artists is
gathered around and everyone else is
working diligently i'm gonna see if i
can infiltrate and work my way around
the studio without any of them noticing
this one seems to like kind of want to
work and stuff yeah
there we go
yeah about six months ago we really need
to get their conditions fixed again
it said something about falling off the
ladder before so it wasn't desired
gas from soap uh
really yeah which crates are very cool
but i bet it looks very convincing but
yeah i can give you some of that stuff
would have to be tomorrow but yeah so i
think what he's describing there's a lot
of cables around here that actually
needs to be directed like i don't know
what we have to get some of these little
things like uh fire shorted and dusted
it's all over
huh
oh sorry can you not they don't want he
doesn't want you to oh you didn't want
this cleaned yeah did you not run in
your office
do you not want to stand
up in here clark kent style oh it's
party party
[Music]
[Applause]
that blew my mind a little bit
yeah
yeah it got
[Music]
you're like i'm superman all right i
think that worked pretty well only maybe
dean noticed it was me and the rest of
the guys had no idea but griffin has
been in his headphones this entire time
and still doesn't know
now it's time to take this to the next
level and have a little fun with it
uh
no not really because griffin doesn't
really get hot
which one's your grip right there yeah
yeah really you don't use that a lot do
you this one's just yeah
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sorry chris he's like
doing yeah
is that important i don't know if that's
a is that hard
hey
hey
[Applause]
well the uh the ac guy came in he takes
his mask off it's been jake the whole
time
i knew something was up when he started
like messing with my camera i was
supposed to be like buddy the air
conditioner is not plugged into my power
strip
that's not a remote battery it's just a
little bit trippy when you think this
figure over here that's kind of in my
peripherals is just uh like a
maintenance guy or someone and then just
completely 180s on you and it's like
your i disables my mind for a second or
like
what is happening
you know what the thing is jake never
wears a mask
[Laughter]
okay for the final test sam spencer and
carmichael are all downstairs on the
main studio floor setting up for son of
a dungeon i think this will finally
prove that jerry jenkins is real
[Music]
yeah i remember the letter for you jared
[Music]
okay jerry
got the ladder for you jerry
looks like this one's the same as the
others were they all installed at the
same time uh
there's a cup
yeah a couple installed later
it's too much different or else you will
disappear and here they have the pumps
oh
the air conditioning guys
i wonder
jerry i don't know if there's a thingy
right there
you know you know what you guys could
use around here is you could probably
use superman
wow
wow wait for real
she said an ac guy was coming today i
was like did he just touch my light
and then he starts picking up like yo
sam is this guy intruding on us
wow
wow
that worked perfectly together
suspicious now
you did it again jake you did it again
that was good good prank that was really
good wow solid prank guys good you're
like you were walking good job like four
or five times i didn't even like look up
and i see this
dude like just another dude in the
studio
bravo you've done it again oh my god
so take that nico i think this evidence
speaks for itself
[Laughter]
the thing is those lights
some of the lights when you're scanning
would die all the time so when a light
goes off i don't ever think anything of
it
that was really fun to watch um
so technically i think you succeeded
though i will point out you're not
walking around with just glasses and a
curl we all know how that test went
that's true i give you that but also i'm
not an alien and so i think superman
might be able to get away with it given
that not everyone he works with outside
of lois lane has like seen superman face
to face like i think we've proven here
is that like if clark kent walked into
starbucks and ordered a coffee the
barista wouldn't know that that's
superman however if clark kent continued
to work with a photographer at the daily
planet who takes pictures of superman
day after day i think that photographer
would probably get the connection yeah
there'd probably be an issue
it's a little thin i'll be honest the
whole glasses disguise it's a little
thin i think the other takeaway is that
clark ken should have a limp talking a
weird voice i'm just a little more clock
cat
the mask does a lot of work but that
being said like your body language your
voice your overall presence was enough
to fool me what do you think you think
we should do this again yeah if we can
think of another like real life
superhero thing to test i think would be
great to do yeah if you guys have any
good ideas let us know in the comments
because i would love to do another one
of these let us know i'll try it and of
course subscribe to the channel if you
want to see us eventually take that idea
and bring it to fruition